Sag mal was ich mich ja noch gefragt habe hast du eigentlich bei der Europawahl auch für diese verbotspartei gestimmt.
Nein ich habe noch nie im Leben.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 305 vom 12. Juni 2019 so siehts aus -
Linus von Neumann.
Ach bist du derjenige der diesen Computergeschichte erfunden hat.
Du und du bist sag noch mal Theodor Prinz von und zu Guttenberg Theodor Prinz der tapfere.
Hüter der Flamme des Herzens Haus der Apostel der Iris.
Kannst jetzt noch mal ein Stück sein.
Theodor Prinz der tapfere Hüter der Flamme des Herzens Haus der Apostel der Iris.
Ja und ich bin Linus von Neumann wir wollen einfach ein bisschen auch unsere credibility gegenüber der Frankfurter Allgemeinen Zeitung hier zeigen.
Auch wir blicken auf lange.
Traditionsreicher Stammbäume in Deutschland Europa zurück und sind damit qualifiziert Quatsch zu reden.
Das nicht so dass wir jetzt einfach so daher gelaufen werden im Internet oder so.
Nein wir plappern auch nicht einfach irgendwelchen Mist aus YouTube Videos nach sondern wir recherchieren dann hat dann heute folgende Themen.
Die Innenministerkonferenz dabei spezifisch die beiden Themen mal Themen Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung und.
Pinkes wie man bei man darf ja nicht Alexa Siri oder ok Google sagen dann re.
Hey Siri heißt das hey Siri.
Hey Siri tschuldigung dann reden wir über die AK Klarnamenpflicht.
Das Auslieferungsverfahren gegen Julien Assange das da lag der Woche dieses Mal in den USA.
Neue Gesetze gegen Influenza und komplett für den Termin.
Ja heute ist der Abendessen Auftakt zur Innenministerkonferenz glaube ich und morgen geht's.
Was hat da was wir da so gereicht.
Ich bin mir nur ich hoffe nur die haben gute Vorkoster ne weil das.
Ja das wäre zu wünschen.
Es wäre ich das wäre ja wirklich schade wenn da irgendwie sind Tropfen schlechte Milch.
Am Risotto wär oder ja das waren wir natürlich nicht.
Also,
die Erin Ministerkonferenz findet ja statt werden letzte Woche schon kurz darüber gesprochen als es um
dieselkrise gesamte Alexa Thematik gegen
die Beschlussvorlage das ist ja auch geil ne also ich meine ich werde durchaus zu der ein oder anderen conferenze eingeladen wo ich dann auch hingehe.
Aber wo ich immer vorsichtig bin sind solche Sachen wollte ich schon mal hier ist übrigens was die Konferenz beschließen wird,
wollen Sie kommen
für Ihre für ihre Unterschrift unter unserem Positionspapier zahlen wir Ihnen zwei Nächte Hotel downtown
okay aber bei solchen Konferenz ist es ja tatsächlich da werden dann Beschlussvorlagen ein gewartet kommen da die ganzen Innenminister zusammen und wir haben in der letzten Folge ja schon darüber gesprochen das ist da unter anderem das aus um das Auswerten von.
Alexa und IOT Daten ginge die Berichterstattung dazu war sehr durchwachsen weil man konnte es zu der Beschlussvorlage im Prinzip 16/17 Innenminister Fragen ja Bund und Länder.
Und alle hatten unterschiedliche unterschiedliche Meinungen und Hintergründe dazu.
Fakt ist dass das hier letzte Woche schon vorsichtig spekuliert habe scheint sich zumindest nach aktueller Aktenlager als richtig zu erweisen dass es da
erstmal nur,
um den Aufbau von Kompetenzen geht und nicht unbedingt darum den großen Lauschangriff auszuweiten auf Alexa Lautsprecher aber wie das so ist mit solchen Warnungen und Entfernungen
mit diesem Bundesinnenminister ist alles möglich und das zeigt eben auch die Debatte.
Um den Zugriff auf Ende zu Ende verschlüsselte Messenger da hatte Horst Seehofer ja vor zwei Wochen so seinen ersten.
Seine erste Arschbombe ins kalte Wasser gemacht wo er nämlich sagt er möchte diese Messenger-Dienste auf die ein oder auf die andere Weise bestimmt ist noch nicht wie.
Zum dazu zwingen Zugriff zu Ende und da möchte ich vielleicht noch mal ganz.
Noch noch einmal drauf eingehen weil wir da jetzt auch
mit einem Seat mit einem offenen Brief und vielen vielen Unterzeichnerin and Chaos Computer Club gehört zu den erst unterzeichnen ehemalige Bundesjustizministerin Sabine Leutheusser-Schnarrenberger mehrere
Datenschutzbeauftragte ehemalige und aktive wir haben irgendwie
Phil Zimmermann dabei den Erfinder von PGP den Bundesverband der mittelständischen Wirtschaft de ECO Verband der Internetwirtschaft Human Rights Watch Reporter ohne Grenzen Wikipedia Deutschland Wissenschaftler Informatiker Bürgerrechtler also einmal so richtig
richtig großer offener Brief der sich gegen dieses Vorhaben wendet und ich würde das gerne noch mal.
Ausführlich erklären woher diese Debatte kommt und warum wir die auch immer wieder haben und zwar.
Ist es so dass wir in Deutschland und in den meisten anderen Land,
dieser Erde für Kommunikationsdienste einerseits so ein Grund.
Gesetzlichen Schutz haben.
Dass deren dass die Vertraulichkeit und das Geheimnis der Kommunikation hier gesichert sein muss Brief Post und Fernmeldegeheimnis.
Und dann kommt bei jedem unserer Grundrechte kommt ja immer so ein außer es sei denn und.
Dann gibt es gesetzliche Regelung die z.b. klären unter welchen Bedingungen nach richterlicher Anordnung das Fernmeldegeheimnis verletzt werden darf unter welchen Bedingungen das Briefgeheimnis verletzt werden darf und soweit.
Das heißt also auch jeder jeder Kommunikationsdienste man in Deutschland so angeboten bekommt muss eine abhör Möglichkeit bieten und das war z.
Das große Thema die älteren unter euch erinnern sich bei der dem er wo man gesagt hat okay wir müssen wir wollen irgendwie etwas bauen was besser ist als E-Mail weil E-Mail eben
unverschlüsselt Feldspat und so weiter ist ein ein in die Jahre gekommenes föderiertes System mit relativ viel.
Architektonischen Schwächen die wir da jetzt auch nicht mehr rausbekommen also E-Mail Spoofing ist eines der.
Der offensichtlichsten ja die für die mangelnde Verschlüsselung die ist eines der eines der offensichtlichen Probleme und die sollten dann somit.
De-Mail gelösten wo man also gesagt hat jetzt machen wir das aber hier verschlüsselt und zwar,
also irgendwie wir nennen das mal ende-zu-ende verschlüsselt quasi und außerdem bringen wir da.
Verschiedene Möglichkeiten ein z.b. die Zugangs Benachrichtigung so festen Standard,
das
um so den rechtssicheren Schriftverkehr viel für jedermann zu ermöglichen und das ist tatsächlich so ein bisschen Problem wenn du heute etwas wirklich recht sicherzustellen möchtest hast du eigentlich,
immer noch nur die Möglichkeit so ein Einschreiben zu nehmen was jetzt ne also als brauchbare Methode und darauf sollte halt so diese diese De-Mail in die Richtung sollte.
Dummerweise wurde das dann quasi als als als Standard so formuliert dass sie sich überlegt haben wenn wir jetzt hier wirklich was sicheres bauen mit Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung und Signaturen dann können wir das ja gar nicht mehr abhören und so etwas,
können wir ja nicht bauen weil das ist ja nicht in unserem Sinne und damit wurde dann dieser ganze De-Mail Standard letztendlich wieder kaputt gemacht und unter den
unter das Sicherheitsniveau gehoben was quasi zu diesem Zeitpunkt mit.
Die GP erreicht werden konnte um quasi nicht einen sicheren Kommunikationskanal zu bauen was zu dem absurden Ergebnis führten.
Erstens ist hat sich tatsächlich nicht durchgesetzt niemand hat dem L am Ende nutzen wollen das sind irgendwie einstellige Anzahlen von von Demenz die irgendwie zu Testzwecken heute noch über diese Server gehen
und mehr ist da nicht passiert und auch relativ,
kurz darauf ja nachdem diese De-Mail Debatte dann irgendwann durch war wollte WhatsApp nämlich Post Norden die Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung auf und damit war WhatsApp
ironischerweise inzwischen sicherer als die De-Mail.
Die ihr wieder große Standard sein sollte mit dem Deutschland sich hier gerühmt hat im Rahmen deren.
Der Wirtschaftsförderung der e-justice Förderung und der E-Government Förderung dass so ein bisschen der bisschen zum Kontext ich hab damals einen Vortrag dazu gehalten auf dem 30 C3 also ist jetzt.
5 und halbgare her mit dem Titel Bullshit made in Germany wo ich das noch mal so ein bisschen damals rekapituliert habe und auch hier im Logbuch haben wieder relativ oft zugesprochen ich war damals als
ich habe für diesen demecan zweimal allein als Sachverständiger im Bundestag um den Sex lernt dass es da eben ein bisschen.
Nicht so nicht so geil ist ne und jetzt haben sie.
Natürlich mit der mit der Verbreitung von verschlüsselten Messengern.
Hat der Sicherheitsstaat der Überwachungsstaat seine Probleme,
und dieses Problem soll im Prinzip auf zwei Weisen begegnet werden dass eine die eine Front die wir sehen ist die die wir ja quasi vor zwei Jahren,
zum ersten zum zum wiederholten Male schlimmer verloren haben dass es die Idee der Trojan isierung also Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung bedeutet,
im Prinzip die Verschlüsselung der Nachricht findet beim Absender statt und die Entschlüsselung der Nachricht findet erst beim
Empfänger statt und ist auch nur dort möglich das heißt alles sämtliche an der Weiterleitung der nachrichten Beteiligten Infrastrukturen verkommen jetzt quasi zu einem,
zu einem bitschubser der aber nicht auf die Inhalte blicken kann.
Und das ist ja auch die Kette das ist die gesamte Idee warum man Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung überhaupt macht weil man in den verschiedenen Kontexten immer davon aus.
Eventuell den Kommunikationsnetz nicht trauen zu können einfaches Beispiel ist natürlich wenn man über Funk überträgt ne jeder der an,
nassen Schnürsenkel geeignete Länge in die Luft hält kann diese Nachricht
empfangen also müssen wir eine Verschlüsselung anbringen um unsere Kommunikation hier zu schützen wenn wir Daten durch das Internet senden bei dem wir nie wissen wie es rooted wer da noch alles drin hängt dann,
verwenden wir diese Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung dafür ist dass da dafür wurde das erfunden und davon profitieren Militär,
Wirtschaft Privatpersonen Journalisten wir alle und alles was die Demokratie.
Ausmacht stärkt und so gute Füße stellt täglich wenn also nun,
das was an der Übertragung beteiligt ist nicht mehr zum Abhören der Inhalte geeignet ist gibt eben zwei Möglichkeiten damit umzugehen beide werden von der von der Regierung verfolgt nämlich ah okay dann müssen wir dort hacken.
Wo die fair oder Entschlüsselung stattfindet nämlich am Endgerät das ist also ich sage das auch immer sehr bewusst wenn man jetzt über ne
eine taktische oder nimmt eine strategische Sicherheits Perspektive redet dass er sich natürlich sagt in dem Moment wo du ende-zu-ende verschlüsselt hast du natürlich sehr sehr sehr viel mehr
Angriff Last auf deinem Endgerät na das heißt dort die Verwahrung der Schlüssel und so weiter muss angegangen werden das ist diese gesamte Schiene
TKÜ und online Durchsuchung also du kommentierst verschlüsselt also wollen wir dann Endgerät.
Findet alle zwei Jahre so ungefähr eine Ausweitung der Befugnisse der Strafverfolger,
Stadt die das daneben ausweiten möchte auch auf immer niedrigere Hürden um einen solchen hacking Angriff auf die Endgeräte.
Zu erlauben der 2017 weil ich dazu letztes Mal als Sachverständiger im Bundestag da ging es darum dass auszuweiten auf 16 andere.
Und Kriminalität Form und jetzt gibt's gerade wieder eine Novelle die das jetzt ausreiten will auf quasi wirklich so
absolute Alltagskriminalität im Prinzip egal weshalb gegen dich ermittelt werden soll dieses Ermittlungs,
Instrumentarium soll der Polizei zur Verfügung stehen,
die andere Schiene ist das was Seehofer jetzt macht und zwar zu sagen ne wenn uns diese Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung so Probleme macht dann lass uns die einfach ganz kaputt machen und.
Im Prinzip die Verpflichtung Backdoors zu ermöglichen dazu muss man natürlich die rechtliche Situation eines.
Anbieter für verschlüsseltes Messaging sehen der bietet nämlich nach aktueller Lion Auffassung.
Zwei Sachen an eine App die verschlüsselt und B die Nutzung einer Routing.
Und beides bietet der quasi getrennt voneinander an wenn also nun die Anfrage kommt ey yo hier.
Ich nehme jetzt prima als willkürliches Beispiel sag mal bitte welche mit wem kommuniziert hat und was sie übermittelt haben
als threema Nachrichten übermittlungs Dienstleister sein ja ja hier könnte haben kriegt könnte eh nichts mit anfangen ist verschlüsselt bitte schön,
wobei zu hoffen ist dass sie noch nicht einmal das tun und da möchte jetzt,
Seehofer hin zu sagen naja momentmal ihr könnt diese beiden Sachen nicht getrennt voneinander rechtlich betrachten sondern wir wollen euch zwingen als Telekommunikationsdienstleister und sie ermöglicht die Möglichkeit zu geben.
Die Nachrichten die mit euch gesendet wurden abhören zu können und jetzt gibt es verschiedene.
Möglichkeiten das zu realisieren welche davon Seehofer hier anstrebt.
Ist eigentlich noch nicht wirklich übermittelt es ist aber wahrscheinlich dem Seehofer hoffentlich egal oder bzw Zweifelsfall ist es einfach.
Die schlimmste eine Option wäre dass es das was.
Diese Diskussionen sind jahrzehntealte eine ist das berühmte key Escrow wo
effektiv die Verpflichtung gemacht wird wenn du eine verschlüsselte Nachricht schickst verschlüsselt du die an deinen Empfänger,
oder deine Gruppe von EmpfängerInnen.
Und mindestens noch immer einen weiteren Empfänger und das ist ein dir vom Anbieter oder von der Regierung vorgegebener Schlüssel des Staates.
So dass retrograd jederzeit der Start in diese Nachrichten mit,
dreinblicken kann die andere Möglichkeit wäre das geschieden nur nach richterlicher Anordnung und dann eben quasi nach vorne gerichtet also heute wird entschieden Tim wird abgehört dann bekommst du ein,
Update untergeschoben von sagen wir in dem Fall müssten mitarbeiten.
Prima mit einem zielgerichteten Update an dich und Apple,
weil Apple über den AppStore dir diese Geräte diese
App bereitstellt um Dir quasi die Tim Pritlove Edition des Verkäufers verschlüsselten Messengers zu schicken
die dann diese Zusatzfunktion alität hat die z.b. darin bestehen könnte entweder die Nachrichten mit einem zweiten Schlüssel zu versehen damit.
Strafverfolgungsbehörden die entschlüsseln können oder sowas zu machen wie ok alles was du da rein tippst und alles was du empfängst wird einfach noch mal ausgeleitet an einen anderen an einen anderen Server der eben hier zu überwachungs Zweck.
So jetzt habe ich glaube ich die Idee die das in Missian hat hier ausreichend.
Gewürdigt und neutral dargestellt jetzt zudem. Warum dass so eine riesige.
Also ein riesiges Problem ist.
In Deutschland haben wir seit über 20 Jahren die sogenannten Eckpunkte der deutschen Crypto Politik,
die im Prinzip davon ausgehen Saluki wir wollen die Sicherheit durch Verschlüsselung haben und.
Diese IT Sicherheit brauchen wir für Deutschland in Verwaltung Wirtschaft und Gesellschaft weil wenn das wenn wir das kaputt machen dann können wir auch nicht mehr davon profitieren.
Zweitens würde man nun die Betreiber quasi also ich habe jetzt threema als Beispiel genommen willkürlich SKOS will aber genau sowas was ich Signal Facebook WhatsApp
iMessage und sonstigen sonstige treffen erstens die müssten aktiv.
Die Sicherheit dieser Kommunikation Schwächen das ist nicht irgendwie so ein bisschen hier wir können wir kriegen das mal eben nebenbei hin sondern die müssten aktiv,
Ihr Produkt auf ein schwächeres Sicherheitsniveau.
Und zwar effektiv für uns alle zweitens was ich denke was hier viel zu unter beleuchtet ist hier würde massiv das Vertrauen untergraben was Menschen überhaupt noch in technische Geräte.
Und in die Anbieter haben können ja das klingt jetzt irgendwie mal so ein bisschen Spaß ich so ach ja.
Apple würde dann eben nach Richterbeschluss irgendwie dir meine abhör eine abhör app auf deinen auf dein Handy pushen ja es klingt irgendwie mal so neben nebenbei gesagt aber was bedeutet das denn bitteschön für
die Digitalisierung in Deutschland und weltweit wenn wir den Geräten nicht mehr trauen.
Und den Anbieter nicht.
Werde den Anbietern und damit eben den den Geräten weiterhin was würde passieren.
Mit denjenigen Anbietern und Technologien die sich diesen Möglichkeiten verweigern also.
Es würde.
Apple z.b. apples z.b.
Also Apple würde das ist halt die Frage ja so wenn du wirklich so etwas zum Gesetz machst dann wird Apple sich dämlich mir verweigern können,
weil du nett weil die letztendlich sagen würde okay dann darf das nicht mehr benutzt werden und wissen nicht genau der Punkt dann hätte quasi hättest Du hier einen Hebel solche Technologien und Dienst Angebote einfach zu blockieren,
ja oder mit Strafen das Anbieten solcher Dienstleistungen mit Strafen zu versehen deswegen würde ich dir jetzt gar nicht Apple als Beispiel nehmen sondern,
nimm einfach mal als Beispiel wir setzen uns zwei Wochenenden hin und bauen einen messenger.
Der föderiert arbeitet und über Tor hidden services seine Nachrichten rooted.
Ruckzuck hättest du keinen Dienst keinen Dienstanbieter mehr weil du einen föderiertes System hättest wir könnten darüber Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung machen hatte alles nicht gesehen.
Jetzt müsstest du theoretisch um das zu um das dann wieder zu verhindern hättest du zwei Möglichkeit dass du eigentlich nur eine Möglichkeit du Inter unter bindest das und blockierst das.
Um den Kriminellen und den Terroristen dieser Erde vor denen wir uns alle so fürchten diese Möglichkeit nicht zugeben oder du blockierst es nicht,
und sag ja okay,
85 90 95 Prozent der Menschen kommunizieren jetzt effektiv unverschlüsselt auf die restlichen 5% können wir verzichten aber genau das wären ja dann die kriminelle die du
die du Abhören möchtest auf deren Kommunikation du zugreifen möchtest das heißt du würdest 90/95 99% deiner,
unbescholtenen Gesellschaft Schaden den das Vertrauen in die Anbieter das Vertrauen in ihre eigenen Geräte entziehen.
Nur um am Ende,
die Kriminellen von der normalen Kommunikationsinfrastruktur Weg zu pushen und die bewahren weiterhin den vollständigen Schutz nur deiner eigenen Gesellschaft hast du dann,
geschadet weiterhin.
Ich will nicht nur sagen dass man das Vertrauen verliert das klingt mir ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen zu schwach
wenn man das ganze jetzt mal in punkto Sicherheit Firmen Sicherheit ja leaking von Geschäftsgeheimnissen ist ja das ist ja alles ein echtes Thema insbesondere wenn man sich jetzt im Ausland
bewegter wo man weiß dass diese Infrastrukturen auch in place sind und bestimmte Staaten nichts sehnlicher wünschen als über die Kommunikation von Unternehmen ihren Außendienstmitarbeitern Beratern ECI Profile Personen ja auch nicht nur im wirtschaftlichen Bereich auch im politischen Bereich
ja also wenn Batman das sozusagen alles,
Ofen Tablett serviert wird was was vorher noch eine halbwegs zuverlässige Sicherheit versprochen hat dann schadet es ja auch ein.
Und das ist genau der Grund warum nach meiner Kenntnis.
Selbst so überwachungs wahnsinnige Demokratur and the USA Russland China solche schritte.
Nicht wirklich gehen China bin ich mir nicht sicher ich glaube die haben tatsächlich weil die haben,
standardmäßig solche solche Möglichkeiten sind da sehr viel weniger verbreitet und die gehen dann dann andere Herangehensweise aber die USA spezifisch,
haben genau das nicht getan ja eben genau gesagt okay da bis hier und nicht weiter also selbst die USA selbst und hat Donald Trump haben gesagt ok
den Schutt kann man nicht gehen weil wir uns da sehr viel mehr ins eigene Fleisch schneiden als wir irgendjemand anders überhaupt schaden können da können wir,
als Nation nichts gewinnen und auch als Regierung nichts gewinnen weiterhin stellt sich natürlich die Frage,
dass die Behauptung dass es den also es wird immer
argumentiert mit diesem going dark ja das hatte ich auch hatten wir damals auch in dieser 2017 anhören letzte zu den Staatstrojaner Ausweitung in Deutschland und gesagt wurde ja.
Wir können die die Leute nicht mehr verhaften ja wir müssen.
Also sinngemäß Fantasie Sätze die wir müssen Straftäter laufen lassen.
Weil sie verschlüsselt kommunizieren und wir deswegen keine Beweise für ihre Straftäter schafft fin.
Wurde da wo du eigentlich jemanden sagen so Freundchen wir haben hier
diesen diese Aussage kannst du nicht führen weil wenn du nicht nachweisen kannst dass es keinen Straftäter das ist ein Straftäter ist dann ist es eben auch keiner ja zweitens die Ermittlung würden nun die Ermittlungs Erfolge zurückgehen.
Die die die Polizeibehörden.
Feiern dann wäre das ja ein empirischer Hinweis dafür dass dieses Problem trotzdem existiert ja.
Und auch diese Zahlen bleiben die Strafverfolgungsbehörden schuldig es gibt also tatsächlich
kein empirischen Beleg dafür dass es dass die Ermittlungsbehörden keine Daten hätten und es ihnen daran,
das ist tatsächlich ein Problem wäre das verschlüsselte Kommunikation hier die Strafverfolgung tatsächlich,
behindert und Ermittlungen zum Erliegen gekommen wären oder sonstige wir sehen das an regelmäßigen er mit uns App.
Wir sehen das an den regelmäßiger mit uns Folge neben Drogenhändler und sonstigen mir ist den ja die Nutzung dieser Technologie nachgesagt wird.
Und wir haben hier einfach keinen Einbruch in den Ermittlungserfolg ganz im Gegenteil haben also.
Wieder so ein ein völlig überbordende Ansatz und du findest eben wenn durch wenn jetzt hier wie,
die ich habe initiator war die Stiftung neue Verantwortung die halt gesagt hat okay wenn man diesen offenen Brief an das Innenministerium und an die anderen mit solchen Problemen befassten Ministerien und Behörden
du findest halt ungefähr jeden der dir das unterschreibt Bitkom
ECO alle niemand hat ein Interesse daran ja also Vertreter du findest selten Allianzen sange mal zwischen zwischen Bitkom,
und CCC und Sabine Leutheusser-Schnarrenberger ja das passiert aber das passiert wirklich nicht jeden Tag ja
das jetzt Reporter ohne Grenzen und Vicky Media und ekose auf der Richtung sind ist eine Sache aber wenn er der Bundesverband mittelständischer Wirtschaft und der CCC,
den fahrend und sagen so das geht nicht das hast du selten nur mal so dass es auch natürlich ein Gradmesser dafür Vivi völlig bescheuert eine Idee überhaupt sein kann.
Und ich muss tatsächlich sagen.
Der sei jetzt selten viele haben das bei den uploadfilter angesagt ne uploadfilter war für viele Menschen so ein Moment wo sie gesagt haben die das jetzt machen dann dann,
flippe ich aus und radikalisieren mich gehen den Untergrund und schließe mit dem System ab ne aber wenn.
Sehen wir das effektive Verbot und die in Unterbindung von Verschlüsselungen und kommunikationssicherheit.
2019 ja in einer sich fortschreitend digitalisieren in Gesellschaft das wäre für mich tatsächlich so eine Grenze wo ich aussagen wird okay.
Dann gibt es anders ernsthaft den Glauben an dieses System zu verlieren weil das so
offensichtlich alles auf Spiel setzt ja also mein Mann muss jetzt,
ist jetzt auch nicht selten dass die Entscheidungen insbesondere der CDU CSU letztendlich alles aufs Spiel setzen ja alles schauen wir uns irgendwie Klimapolitik an die sind weit die sind bei dem bleibt kein Auge trocken.
Und die sind bereit massives Schäden in Kauf zu nehmen und das hier wäre ein solcher Fall.
Das scheint ja gerade so ein bisschen so ein Trend zu sein so die Selbstvernichtung.
Global aber auch auch lokal ja also ich spreche es auch mal ganz gerne vom brexit Zeit und nicht vom brexit austritt irgendwie so ein bisschen besser.
Ja okay also du stellst die Systemfrage soweit wieder zurückkommen nach 305 Sendung.
Also für mich ist das also ich,
möchte dieses Thema deshalb also ich habe es ja langsam vor zwei Wochen schon mal angellis kotiert das halte ich für eine der der ganz ganz wichtigen Fragen neben dem nächsten Thema das ist auch sehr sehr wichtig das sind wirklich so.
Diskussionen die interessanterweise immer wieder aufkommen und die eigentlich auch immer.
Zum zum Glück selbst in den USA immer dann noch am Ende im Sinne.
Der Rationalität wieder im Keim erstickt werden und und nicht nicht zu Ende diskutiert werden aber eben auch welche die bei uns alle paar Jahre kommen.
Und bei denen wir jedesmal in aller Schärfe,
erkennt den historischen Kontext und die Bedeutung erklären müssen deswegen wollte ich das heute noch mal so besonders hervorheben weil das wirklich der finale Angriff auf.
Sicherheit und Datenschutz ist und damit einen ein Paradigmenwechsel in allem wie er überhaupt mit Geräten agieren können die wir überhaupt uns digitalisieren.
Ja so siehts aus also wenn ihr da auch in irgendwelchen größeren Unternehmen seit.
Will ich auch durchaus mal Kontakt mit der Geschäftsführung aufnehmen ob die sich nicht solchen Initiativen auch mal anschließen oder mindestens ihrem übergeordneten Verband welche auch immer das sein mag sagen sich solcher
Aktivitäten mal anzuschließen da kann man sicherlich ne ganze Menge erreichen auch aus mittelständischen oder auch
das ist so schön KMU-Bereich da ist das ist auch erstmal das ist auch eine Sprache die in Deutschland noch verstanden wird,
in der Politik,
so na wenn die Unternehmen sich melden mal dass der TTC los great wenn es irgendwie gegen die Freiheit im Netz geht so darstellen die ihre Urlaub nach,
aber wenn,
bin halt der BITKOM kommt so dann rollt der ein oder andere abgeordnetenmitarbeiter schon mit den Augen wendet irgendwie auf dem Bildschirm.
Ja da kann man also die Liste der Unterzeichner ist da wirklich sehr sehr lang und den Brief haben wir verlinkt.
Auf ccc.de ist ja auch veröffentlicht und kann euch gerne anschließen mit euren Unternehmen und Verbänden.
Hatte dann auch einen Clan Namen unterschrieben.
Klar.
Den den Tim für eine offene Gesellschaft ist es schwer erträglich wenn sich die Menschen bei Debatten im Internet nicht offen gegenübertreten.
Privatleute und Person des öffentlichen Lebens werden unter dem Schutz der Anonymität beleidigt und bedroht und das geht nicht na deswegen müssen wir natürlich einen offenen Brief an eine offene Gesellschaft,
mit unseren Acker Klarnamen und unterzeichnen.
Warum zitierst du jetzt irgendwie lnp von 2012.
Ich zitiere vor allem wann Manfred Schäuble Wolfgang Schäuble hat das gesagt ne.
Auf jeden Fall ist diese Debatte ja nicht nur eure und vor allem dieser Mythos Leute würden sicher im Netz nur dann schlecht benehmen wenn sie unter Nicknames Auftreten der ist ja wohl sowas von widerlegt worden von dieser ganzen rechten werde die Welt in den letzten Jahren in,
beobachten durften also sicherlich,
gilt das nicht für alle die da schreien aber es schreien so viele mit Name und Anschrift und Postleitzahl dass man glaube ich einfach diese ganze these
Klarnamen würden jetzt irgendetwas verbessern für die Kommunikationskultur sie kann man einfach mal gleich zusammenfalten im Papierkorb schmeißen das ist einfach Unsinn und wer auch immer jetzt das Ding wieder hervorholt zeigt einfach nur ein weiteres Mal
die generelle Inkompatibilität der eigenen Gedanken mit den Realitäten des Internet.
Ja man muss sich ja nur sagen schauen was so jemand wie Jasper von altenbockum das ist tatsächlich dessen Namen also der Name klingt ja wirklich wie ein in Zement gegossenes Pseudonym.
Ja aber der Mann heißt du und der schreibt unter Klarnamen.
Ja da können wir nachher noch zu.
Was ist passiert.
Also einmal die die Diskussion um Internet Diskussion und Meinungsaustausch hält an
Aufschlag war vor einigen Wochen eben mit dem eben geführten Zitat von Wolfgang schottler Manfred Weber der EVP
Kommissionspräsident Kandidaten hat sich auch schon in der Richtung geäußert und Annegret Kramp-Karrenbauer
er sprach von einem dramatischen Beispiel da nehme ich jetzt tatsächlich ein dramatisches Beispiel der Regierungspräsident.
Von Kassel Herr Lübke getötet wurde gemordet wurde und sich dazu Menschen im Internet gehässig äußert haben.
Ja das ist natürlich.
Am eines nicht unbedingt eine der Sternstunden des Netzes aller.
Zingst,
weiß ich nicht ob es ein Anschlag auf die Grundregeln des Zusammenlebens ist für die CDU Chefin sagt und es müsste jetzt darüber geredet werden ob im Netz alles erlaubt sein dürfte kannst du auch schon ja
haha ich genau alles ist erlaubt im Netz wir leben hier im rechtsfreien Traum ja wir können alles machen was wir wollen wir haben will eigentlich sowas wie.
Wie wie die Gesetze oder netzpolitische Auseinandersetzungen haben wir eigentlich gar nicht ne.
Mit mir also welchem alubeschichtete
Besenkammer Hanse die eigentlich im Saarland rausgeholt als ich also da Folgerungen von Angela Merkel geworden ist hat die irgendwelche Funksignal erhaltene der letzten Dekade oder muss sie sich jetzt das im Prinzip alles noch mal komplett neue Arbeit.
Sie sagt das ist auch geil also dich die Formulierung sind schon echt krass ob nicht eine strengere Netiquette nötig.
Sodass diese 25 Jahre alte wollte jetzt langsam.
Und vor allem die die Netiquette ist ja die freiwillige Selbstverpflichtung.
Ja da steht ja die CDU drauf.
Und nicht die AKK sagt ich möchte wissen wer hinter solchen Kommentaren steckt.
Ändert doch auch nichts wenn du weißt wer dahintersteckt,
ja und es geht jetzt die es geht jetzt also in die Richtung na wir merken die CDU CSU EVP schießen sich darauf ein.
Eine Klarnamenpflicht im Internet durchzusetzen auch dass keine neue Forderungen weißt du noch Tim wann sie zum ersten Mal kam.
Klarnamenpflicht.
Die Forderung nach kleiner Pflicht.
In in Deutschland.
Egal wo das lass mich raten also haben wir jetzt 19 Uhr das Ding ist also mindestens zehn Jahre für diese Diskussion wenn nicht schon bisschen länger.
Natürlich auch sein ich weiß es nämlich auch nicht.
Also naja also ich würde mal sagen so lange haben wir jetzt Twitter Wasser und.
Seit irgendjemand
irgend also ich würde sagen seit irgendwann mal jemand im Internet etwas geschrieben hat was jemand anderen nicht gefallen hat und das wird wahrscheinlich relativ lange her sein
ja das hat ja Internet gehört dass er durchaus zu den Gesetzmäßigkeiten dass das regelmäßig passiert dass Menschen da etwas Falsches sagen.
Ja gut ich meine dazu gehört natürlich auch erstmal diese Fähigkeit im Netz überhaupt selber als Privatperson was zu schreiben bloß wäre das jetzt ungefähr so 15 Jahre alt die ganze Geschichte na das hat so 2000
vier so richtig
angefangen technisch Kings Tattoos schon bisschen früher aber vorher war das auf Seiten aufsetzen von Webseiten wo die ja generell noch als Visitenkarte im Netz gezeichnet wo man nur dachte man müsste da irgendwelche Pappaufsteller digitalisieren um sich da irgendwie zu präsentieren für eine halbe Million
euro-pro HTML-Datei und als im Block.
So teuer die die damals verkauft hin.
Ich.
Hoyerswerda.
Haben sich auf jeden Fall einige einige schon eine goldene Nase mitverdienen ne und manche sicherlich auch eine goldene Nase Scheidewand
also das ist insofern nichts Neues und natürlich in dem Moment wo Social Media richtig auf dem Plan kam also im Prinzip auch so
na YouTube ging's ja los ist aber am Anfang nicht wirklich also schon wieder wahrgenommen worden und dann halt der Aufstieg von Twitter und Facebook dann ging es halt los.
Ich muss da mal also glaube ich das ist auch,
insbesondere jetzt in so einem harten Fall wird irgendwie Mord und dann Helme von irgendwelchen rechtsradikalen menschenverachtenden Idioten das ist natürlich ein,
Extrembeispiel und sicherlich nicht schön.
Ich habe aber wahrscheinlich auch die nicht besonders,
und auf Anhieb nicht besonders Popi populäre Haltung dass es relativ egal ist wer etwas sagt.
Hamm.
Denke die eine Äußerung muss für sich stehen und muss auch für sich diskreditiert oder diskreditiert war sein ja das ob die Äußerung.
Anonym getätigt wird oder nicht sollte für den Inhalt und die Bewertung der Äußerung völlig egal sein natürlich ist es kein.
Keine schöne Situation wenn hier aus bisher ungeklärten Umständen einen Mord geschieht ist ist,
gibt da verschiedene naheliegende Verdächtigungen weil der ja auch vorher schon aus dem rechtsradikalen Spektrum bedroht wurde der Mann wir haben es hier unter Umständen mit dem.
Mit einem krassen politisch motivierten Mordfall zu tun also wirklich auch etwas wowow.
Mit zu verstehen ist und natürlich ist es fürchterlich wenn Menschen darüber auch noch hämische Witze machen,
ich würde aber trotz allem Ja und ich verzweifle ja selber regelmäßig an der und der Kommunikation und dem Austausch
und im Verlauf dieser dieser Debatten die Menschen im Internet führen ja das treibt mich ja selber regelmäßig in in in finstere,
Träume Herr und nimmt mir viel Hoffnung wie ich auf dieses Leben blicke aber die Möglichkeit der anonymen oder pseudonym Kommunikation,
aufzugeben daran würde ich selbst in den finstersten Situation nicht denken.
Hallo muss halt noch mal klarmachen,
solange sich diese Debatte lange handelt und warum es eigentlich generell ne schlechte Idee ist eine solche Klarnamenpflicht einzuführen also erstmal darf ich diese Debatte halt um die Verfolgbarkeit von Straftaten die sich natürlich auch in solchen Meinungsäußerungen,
Verleumdung Beleidigung ihr ca dieser schlagen kann dass das so zeigen hier das Leid
Mutti Fluss in gewisser Hinsicht auch nachvollziehbar Problem ist dass er diese Klarnamenpflicht nicht herstellbar ist
also die ist vielleicht kann man jetzt,
weite Wege gehen und wieder Anbieter verpflichten Überprüfungen zu machen da müssen wieder 1000000000,
Führerscheine und Personalausweise gescannt und unverschlüsselt übers Netz übertragen werden Wasser noch mal so ein eigenes Problem für sich scharf da oder man hat irgendwelche zentralisiert
hat regulierten identitäts Systeme die am Ende auch alle scheitern werden man sieht ja schon welche schwierig.
Die Bundesrepublik Deutschland damit hat ihren schönen digitalen Personalausweis mal hier als Ausweis
Bella und Sultan identitätsquelle einzuführen das wird halt nicht funktionieren das andere.
Also im Moment Moment Moment Moment da habe ich Geld ich da hätte ich zwei Punkte zu anzumerken aber okay sprich erstmal zu Ende ich bin mal gespannt was du noch hast.
Das andere ist natürlich schlecht das natürlich Anonymität nicht perse etwas Schlechtes ist
ja dass das mag in diesem einen Fall kontraproduktiv sein für Ermittlungen von Behörden aber natürlich ist Anonymität auch,
ein Schutz für viele Leute ein Schutz für Menschen die eben aus welchen Gründen auch immer Diskriminierung oder Benachteiligung erfahren müssen sei es auf Basis von Geschlecht 6 oder Zuneigung oder
anderen
Eigenschaften die man vielleicht mit sich bringt die einen als Minderheit oder als verfolgte Minderheit ausweisen und genau an der Stelle muss es eben auch möglich sein einen solchen Diskurs führen zu können
ohne eben gleich vollständig darzulegen wer man ist wo man wohnt wo man arbeitet mit wem man Freund ist etc
und insofern ist es eben auch hochgradig kontraproduktiv für die Gesellschaft selbst wenn es irgendwelche zu argumentierenden Vorteile für Strafermittlung Behörden gibt
das ist ja nicht das A&O.
Dazu ist erstmal anzumerken gerade er,
Donnerstag den was heißt denn 5. Juni oder 6. Juni wie auch immer vor wenigen Tagen gab es,
in 13 Bundesländern insgesamt 38 Wohnungsdurchsuchungen wo Verdächtige festgenommen wurden die hasskommentare,
im Netz hinterlassen haben sollen,
also du so in 13 Bundesländern bei achten in 38 Fällen Durchsuchung und Vernehmung von Verdächtigen auch hier stellt sich wieder die Frage wo ist denn.
Schutzlücke die überhaupt.
Eine solche Maßnahme erlauben würde wenn heute jemand tatsächlich eine strafrechtlich relevante Äußerung im Netz,
pathetisch sagen wir mal dann auch noch in einem Forum.
Das als dass ausreichend viele Menschen erreicht sei es Facebook-Seite Twitter-Seite Instagram ja woanders erreichst du ja kaum noch Menschen da ist auf deiner eigenen Webvisitenkarte gut,
in all diesen Fällen gibt es sehr einfache sehr vielversprechende Möglichkeiten diesen Menschen diesen Menschen strafrechtlich beizukommen und wir sehen die Erfolge dieser Möglichkeiten in,
dieser Polizeiaktion der vergangenen Woche ja wir sehen dass das funktioniert.
Wir haben hier keinen,
keine Schutzlücke die gerade das Internet bedrohen würde ja wir haben weitreichende Pflichten der Provider mitzuwirken in der Aufklärung,
solcher Fälle wir haben mit dem netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz weitreichende,
Möglichkeiten auf eine sofortige Löschung hinzuwirken was wenn man jetzt aus AKK Perspektive argumentiert natürlich das ultimative,
Schutzziele hier ist dass solche bei der strafrechtlich relevante Äußerungen hier verschwinden,
es gibt aber und darüber sprechen wir immer wieder den sehr breiten Teil der strafrechtlich nicht relevanten Äußerungen die trotzdem dir eine ganze Menge Ärger eintreten können z.b.
Wenn du als halbwegs bekannter Youtuber erst wagst,
dich öffentlich zu äußern und dann damit rechnen muss dass das die Bild-Zeitung mehr oder weniger deine Identität preisgibt an irgendwelche Spinner die an Twitter hängen und den ganzen Tag nur in welche Verschwörungstheorien über dich
verbreiten wie z.b. gesagt hat Jasper von altenbockum das mit dem Riesen macht ja es ist also ganz klar dass,
wir für normale legitime ganz klar von der Meinungsfreiheit gedeckt und für die Gesellschaft positive Meinungsäußerung durchaus.
Die anonymen Anonymität und pseudonymität gebrauchen können und was würde passieren wenn wir diese opfern,
dann haben wir eine einen sogenannten chilling effect also einen Einschüchterung ceffect bei jedem Menschen der sich irgendwo als hat,
wo du dir dann irgendwann die Frage stellst möchte ich jetzt hier Donald Trump in diesem Tweet öffentlich kritisieren oder nicht wenn ich berücksichtige das,
im Zweifelsfall in zwei Jahren ist diese Social Media Konto bei der Einreise angeben muss möchte ich mich möchte ich das rezo Video liken wenn ich,
hier letztendlich von der von von der Regierung erfasst bin und,
du hast gerade gesagt Deutschland kriegt das wieder nicht hin das ist das letzte worauf ich mich verlassen möchte das Deutschland dass wir da nicht hin kriegt der Gesetzesentwurf aus Österreich den wir hier regelmäßig besprochen haben wo es um eine solche.
Klarnamenpflicht bzw Synonym zu Klarnamenpflicht gibt es ja den Begriff der des Vermummungsverbot ist wo das relativ einfach gelöst wurde.
Immense Geldstrafen für die Provider wenn sie nicht die Identitäten der der der Nutzerinnen und Nutzer rausrücken können,
im Bedarfsfall,
technologieneutral wie sie denn diese Identifikation vornehmen wollen ob sie jetzt über SMS mit SIM-Karte ob sie vielleicht unter Nutzung
Bierbecher e-id Verfahren videoident ist in doch völlig egal so ich glaube nicht dass es große,
Problem Probleme gebe so etwas bei dem größeren Teil der Kommunikationsmöglichkeiten,
die Menschen hier nutzen problemlos umzusetzen und du hättest dann wieder den Effekt dass es den DD die Kleinen,
einfachen Leute trifft,
die daneben überlegen okay krass egal was ich hier schreibe letztendlich genieße ich nicht den Schutz der Anonymität nicht den den Schutz meiner meiner meiner Identität.
Und er und den diesen Schutz genieße ich auch in den Entwicklungen der nächsten 10 20 30 Jahren nicht,
unter Betrachtung welche vielleicht noch alles an an an die Macht kommt in diesem Land weil ich mich einmal identifiziert habe.
Und das kombiniert ja also Klarnamenpflicht.
Kombiniert wird Verbot verschlüsselter Kommunikation ja dann brauchst du dich wirklich wirklich wirklich nicht mehr irgendwie moralisch über eine eine Regierung wie
China zu stellen und die genau diese Option bereithält nutzt und anwendet.
Ja dann lass uns doch noch mal hier über diese konkrete Auseinandersetzung mit den neuen Influenza sprechen und was denn jetzt hier die Fahrt wieder falsch gemacht.
Also derzeit ist er die Influenza sind ja derzeit die Influenza der Politik die haben sich ja alle Angehörigen Schnupfen
geholt an dieser ganzen Debatte wie war das eben auch schon erwähnt haben das einfach
es sich hier zeigt dass ihr einfach nicht mit dem richtigen Besteck unterwegs sind um diese Kröten zu schlucken gehen jetzt gerade vorgehalten werden
und na ja insgesamt denke ich mal gibt's hier aber auch verschiedene Problem,
lagen einerseits gibt ja auch so diese rechtliche Auseinandersetzung mit Werbung na also mit dieser neuen Werbe Öffentlichkeit die jetzt so mit dieser Begriff influencer ist er jetzt,
eigentlich neu auf dem Tisch als politisches Statement da war ja bisher eigentlich eine reine finanzielle refinanzierungs Geschichte eine Influenza sind Leute die haben halt,
Einfluss weil ihn viele Leute Folgen aus welchen Gründen auch immer da wird viel mit Belanglosigkeiten gearbeitet ne also die oft zitierten schminktips erzählt das kann man alles scheiße finden oder so aber.
Du könntest ja auch mal den ein oder anderen schminktipp abholen wenn du wieder den Aufstieg von Union gefeiert hast gesagt das wäre so belanglos.
Deswegen mache ich ja auch nichts auf YouTube ne damit ich in diese Situation gar nicht erst kommen.
Die eine Hälfte des Gesichtes weiß die andere Hälfte des Gesichtes rot Schminktipps von Tim Pritlove.
Podcast addict mir wird dann kann ich mich daher umfangreich im Internet informieren
Angebote gibt ja genug na und wo geht man dann dahin da geht man dann zu diesem populären hübschen jungen schönen Menschen die alle so begehrenswert aussehen oder zumindest daher reden,
und die ihre große Fanbasis haben und dann eben diese aggregierten zahlen ja neun Öffentlichkeiten die sie dort geschaffen haben daneben gewinnbringend vermarkten indem sie sich eben ja.
Sag mir mal kapitalistischen kapitalistischen Grundthemen zuwenden.
Aber du tust ja jetzt oder oder du stellst jetzt jetzt fast so da ist mir das irgendwie was was Neues dass Menschen mit einem
Angebot sei ist eine Zeitung sei es eine TV-Sendung sei es eine Radiosendung Aufmerksamkeit generieren und dann teile der Aufmerksamkeit die sie bekommen,
anderen verkaufen ja also das ist ja so werden ja die die Massenmedien.
Dadurch werden die an auch wenn ich es schön finde wenn es anders wäre aber dadurch werden dir
im Prinzip am Laufen gehalten dadurch sind viele Podcasts finanziert dadurch sind ist ein großer Teil des Fernsehens finanziert
und eben auch ein Teil der YouTube Kanäle was was macht denn jetzt was macht denn jetzt die Influenza anders.
Neu ist vor allem dass es sich hier primär um Einzelpersonen zumindest in der öffentlichen Wahrnehmung stattfindet behandelt ne also klar mittlerweile
arbeitet jeder gute Youtuber auch schon mit einem Team Mörder wird nicht unbedingt die Kamera mal wieder selber eingerichtet da ist sicherlich der eine andere schminktipp auch am Start
bzw es gibt natürlich auch vermarktungs Geflechte mittlerweile ne
eigentlich alle großen Youtuber gehören irgendeinem vermarktungs Partnerring mit Andy daneben diese ganze Werbung überhaupt erst dorthin bringen weil darum will man sich dann im Einzelnen ja auch nicht unbedingt mit drum kümmern dann wird er das Geld entsprechend
geteilter Marktkauf verschiedene abweichende Modelle geben aber im Großen und Ganzen ist es so
neues halt einfach nur dass eben jetzt die Politik geht auch sieht und sich aber auch
juristischer mit auseinandersetzen muss oder gibt's da z.b. die ganze Debatte um was ist denn jetzt Schleichwerbung ja also wenn ich jetzt irgendwie auf meinem Kanal
über irgendwelche Produkte daher Rede und auf irgendwas linke ja
betrifft mich ein Podcast auch ne was ist wenn ich jetzt hier über neue Apple watch daher Phase und um wie auf eine Produktseite verlinke ist denn das dann schon Werbung ne oder oder nicht dann gab's ja auch diesen einen Fall der letzten Wochen rum gegangen ist von dieser Cathy Hummels die.
Genau das getan hat in dem Fall ging das glaube ich um Instagram ist von so einem schönen Abbauen von zum abmalen Verband mit dem schönen Abend
Verband sozialer Wettbewerb verklagt worden.
Sozialer Wettbewerb.
Wir haben alle gewonnen.
Ja
Wir haben alle den besten Platz.
Genau wir wollen auch was abhaben von deinem Geld.
Your special just like everyone else.
Genau Landgericht München hat sich in dem Fall allerdings so geäußert ganz interessante Argumentation
naja das ist ja nicht direkt Geld für bezahlt worden also es war jetzt nicht offensichtliche Werbung weil sie meinte ja sie habe das aus reiner Begeisterung gemacht und es sei insofern keine.
Lauter Begeisterung noch Geld dafür bekommen oder.
Nein sie hat nicht nein also sie ist,
danke jetzt die Faktenlage nicht aber das ist sozusagen wie sie es dargestellt hatten ihr das Gericht das wohl auch geglaubt hat dass in dem Fallen sind Betroffenen Dingern eben nicht Schleichwerbung gemacht wurde im Sinne von da ist dann auch
geschlossen sondern sei kein Geld geflossen das ist aber sich trotzdem alles in einem kommerziellen Umfeld ab,
das sei ja ersichtlich weil sonst hätte man ja gar nicht so einen Kanal und würde gar nicht diesen zeitlichen Aufwand treiben diesen zu befüllen
jetzt möchte auch das Justizministerium hier das wurde zum ist vom Staatssekretär in seinem Interview nebenbei angekündigt dass in diese grenzende auch mal neu festlegen um sozusagen Clara festzulegen was ist aber ich wollte erstmal nur darauf gekommen diese Debatte existiert jetzt können wir wieder auf diesen Fall
die du vorhin schon mehrfach,
angesprochen hast du da wirklich zunehmendem Maße sehr unterhaltsamen Debatte im mit und Umrisse.
Der auf Twitter auch aktiv ist und dort massig quotiert wird und entsprechend auch hier mal antwortet.
Ging dann irgendwie jetzt auch die Fahrt Stall und der FAZ Innenpolitik Chef,
von dir schon erwähnt Jasper von altenbockum.
Künstlername.
Man man hört in den Bezug zur Arbeiterklasse deutlich heraus.
Ein Proletarier bis ins Mark.
Genau und der hat nämlich im Internet video.
Da stand drin der ist ja der arbeitet ja für vermag das ja alles bezahlt ja so ein Betrug.
Oh das ist ja auch sowieso diese erste Reaktion der CDU oder konservativen die digital unterwegs sind so nach dem Motto ja wer ist denn das überhaupt da kommt einer der der verdient ja Geld im Internet und jetzt redet er auch noch schlecht über uns das
kann ja alles nur eine abgekartete Sache sein offensichtlich was kein wiederaufkommen aber vielleicht kennen die das gar nicht anders.
Was ich eigentlich viel schlimmer finde ist ja wenn jemand wenn jemand sich gebiert wie alten Jasper von altenbockum und noch nicht mal gekauft ist hier das ist doch viel schlimmer.
Das wissen wir ja nicht das wissen wir ja nicht da kann man nichts zu sagen.
Kinderdecke die wie die die machen ich habe weißt du was ich gehört habe Tim haben die Frankfurter Allgemeine Zeitung ne die Arbeiten gewinnorientiert.
Ja doch da kannst du anzeigen kaufen.
Wer hat die bezahlt.
Wer hat die Witze.
Na gut was ist passiert er altenbockum ein bisschen im Internet recherchiert und Anführungsstrichen.
Nicht seine Stärke muss man sein.
Nicht unbedingt und er ist dann irgendwie auf so ein,
Totilas unrechten vortella geraten Aquarium der irgendwie auch ganz gerne mal so Israel und schwulenfeindlich ist verbreitet das aber nicht gefunden sondern nur ebenso ein und das ja sowieso übliches Dinge in rechten Kreisen na dann nimmt man so.
Beginner der wollte mal seine,
kann mir doch keinen Vorwurf machen weil es ist klar der YouTube Algorithmus der gibt dir immer das wo was du brauchst ne insofern wahrscheinlich hat er noch nicht mal aktiv
diese rechten Verschwörungstheoretiker und Schwulenhasser gesucht sondern YouTube hat natürlich relativ einfach gesagt guck mal das könnte dir gefallen und hatte ja auch recht ne also da muss man ja auch durchaus diese Algorithmen von YouTube mal würdigen.
Genauso wird es passiert sein oder hat er sich das Video angeschaut hat sich gedacht du port nein wirklich also das is,
unglaublich Empörung und es gleich los marschiert und hat sich sozusagen in dem frisch ausgelegten Fettnäpfchen selbst frittiert indem man das dann halt
um sich geschmissen hat bis er dann irgendwie so von allen und rezo auch selber drauf hingewiesen wurde dass es einfach mal alles vollkommen Humbug ist und er gerade dabei ist hier irgendwie
mit Propaganda die beleglos ist im Internet weiterzuverbreiten musste sich dann am Ende auch entsprechend kleinlaut zurückziehen hatte auch noch so ein paar lustige.
Das ist das ja auf der Zunge zergehen lassen dieser Mann ich weiß nicht seit wie vielen Jahren der der innere vor Chef ist ja und wie viel Jahren bei der Frankfurter Allgemeinen Zeitung ist er dessen Kern Kritik.
Seit Wochen kommt der auch nicht darunter ist dem rezo methodische Mängel.
Unten im Baez zu unterstellen und der kann nicht ein der kann ich ein YouTube Video gucken.
Ohne sich sofort somit mit nur wieso hat weiß wie viel 100 oder 1000 Links waren das unter diesen Video ich weiß es noch nicht mal mehr ne und da kommt dann irgendwann so einer Sache hier also bei Link Nummer 94,
den hatte.
Schon unterschwellig ein bisschen überbewertet in seiner Aussage ja und dann sagt Alter alten Jasper von altenbockum halten mein.
Und sagt ich versuche mal einen Link ein.
Richtig geil deswegen seit 30 Jahren bei der Fahrt.
Ich hätte hier keine geringere Zahl geschätzt du soll er auch sonst sehen.
Oh Mann aufgefallen wurde es richtig schlimm da hat er dann auch noch so ein paar andere Vögel auch mit so klangvollen Namen biofrisch Kiesewetter oder Heribert Hirte die so CDU-Bundestagsabgeordnete sind die dann interessierst,
brauche tweeted haben damit eingestiegen sind nachdem sein und wie klar wollen doch alle bisschen falsch Link wurde es schwierig und dann haben sie sich halt so mit diesem Wort about essen
und na man kann sich ja schon irgendwie rausreden dann öffentlich zur Schau getragen richtig geil fand ich dann den Dialog zwischen Heribert Hirte und Reso härtewert hörte meinte
bei bezahlter Werbung für Parteien ist offenzulegen von wem sie bezahlt wurde und gleich ob Plakat Anzeige oder nicht,
da sind immer noch Fragen offen hatte war überhaupt nicht bereit erstmal einfach nur mal
klein beizugeben sonnendeich noch mal irgendwie ne das kann ja alles nicht sein hinterher so geantwortet hatte ich echt auf dem Boden naja es sind ebenso Fragen offen ob du nachts Nippelklemmen zusammen Karaoke singst und dir vom Hund auch
im Bauchnabel
beides hat keine Belege beides sind Fragen die man halt stellen kann oder man lässt es weil es nur Spekulationen sind.
Oh Mann.
Woraufhin natürlich das Internet jetzt wahrscheinlich alle fünf Minuten fragt ob es denn schon was neues in der Angelegenheit wird in den Oreo Keksen.
Ja die Nippelklemmen Frage ist auch noch vollkommen ungeklärt grandios.
Bild bei Fragen offen.
Wie ist das Essen auf jeden Fall Frage offen also sehr schön auf sehr vielen Ebenen ja klasse muss ich sagen und das ist so ein bisschen so ein AC Moment auch ne wird ja wahrscheinlich auch aus dem Augenwinkel verfolgen.
Alexandria ocasio-cortez.
Claudia einfach die amerikanische Politik von links gerade komplett aufm ist aber insbesondere durch ihre Medienkompetenz einfach hervorsticht und einfach
keinerlei keiner Debatte incana Debatte untergeht weil sie einfach immer wieder so ein Pfiff auch in ihrem,
Schreibstil hat und sich einfach auch nicht so schnell einschüchtern ist ne also dieses Mennige was wir ja vielleicht auch noch ein bisschen drauf habe wird mir wohl seiner beleidigt mir gehen ja gar nicht mit mir rum weil wir einfach noch aus einer anderen Gesprächskultur rauskommen auch wenn.
Ich uns jetzt mal auch unterstellen würden das Wetter vielleicht etwas höheren Härtegrad haben als der Durchschnitt unserer Alters.
Tim ich bitte dich wann habe ich mich erst letzte Woche irgendwann beleidigen lassen.
Na ja du bist ja auch jünger als ich dich meine nur.
Verein der es gibt immer einen der beleidigt und einen der sich beleidigen lässt so und meistens ist der der sich beleidigen lässt der Verlierer.
Ja ja klar also man muss das schon eine gewisse Coolness war aber ich spreche für meine Altersgruppe nicht unbedingt für uns ne so und die ist es halt
die ist es halt nicht so gewollt ne während man halt ganz klar den Events und Teens und wahrscheinlich auch schon in thirties derzeit hat gesagt die Aufnahme dafür
zugute halten kann dass er einfach schon durch diese Stahlbad Internet einmal durchgeweicht worden sind in ihrer Jugend und dementsprechend einfach eine ganz andere Resistenz
an Tag legen und dass ich das jetzt.
Das würde ich da bin ich vorsichtig wäre ich vorsichtig das soweit für interpretieren ich sehe trotzdem auch jeden Tag genug Leute im Internet ausrasten
du darfst in dieser in dieser rezo versus fast Debatte nicht vergessen dass der riesco seit drei Wochen weiß
oder seit zwei Wochen ne3 das Ding habe ich gewonnen und der muss jetzt also der den.
Kann jetzt auch der Kater Jasper von altenbockum jetzt auch zwei Wochen später noch sagen ich ich spuck dir ins Auge und Blende dich und der und rezo keiner sagen so ja.
Habe das keine Beine.
Du hast keine Beine mehr das ist jetzt relativ einfach.
Aber er ist ja auch in dieser Rolle erstmal deshalb gekommen ne also das ist ja so das ist ja nicht ohne Bezug und.
Ich will jetzt auch nicht sagen alle sind so cool sicherlich steht da jetzt in gewisser Hinsicht voraus vor allem als Einzelperson nichtsdestotrotz.
Wenn ich wenn ich eine Hypothese haben dürfte was den was den rezo gestellt hat ne.
Und das glaube ich es wirklich die absolute Härteprüfung weiße in in deiner und meiner Generation spricht man ja so von den von den Usenet gestellten Trollen ne so.
Stell dir mal bitte jemanden vor der Youtuber kommen Tage.
Dagegen ist das Usenet irgendwie ein ein wohlgehütetes Knuddels Forum,
was du auf YouTube für Kommentare liest und ich denke da wird da wird der Riese sein sein Fell her haben,
weil das geht ja wirklich auf keine Kuhhaut das Leute auf YouTube kommentieren dass er wirklich sehr sehr selbst mir
nur in in in besonderen Momenten mit einer Flasche Rotwein zugänglich was was ihr Leute da.
Du weißt ja nicht was die Leute noch alles in ihrem Leben gemacht haben kann auch sein dass sie ein bisschen bei Forza gebadet haben,
ist auf jeden Fall liegt ich sage jetzt einfach mal ganz salopp es liegt generell in dem Jugendlichen Bereich ein anderer Hartungs Grad vor.
Darf ich darf ich kritisch anmerken dass uns gerade relativ weit vom Thema entfernt haben.
Geht so also kommt drauf an was wir jetzt als das Thema bezeichnen also mir geht ja sozusagen um diesen dis
Kurs und was das auch letztlich bedeutet ich fand es jetzt erstmal sehr schön zu sehen dass auch dieser konservative Medien Arm FAZ auf dem Zahnfleisch läuft ja und seine Inkompetenz genauso klar darlegt über bestimmte Personen wie das eben jetzt auch die CDU getan hat
und das Ganze vor dem Hintergrund des wir jetzt diesen na ja.
Shift ich weiß nicht so ganz genau wie du das so interpretierst aber wir hatten jetzt die Europawahl wir haben
Umfrageergebnisse ja wir wissen alle dass kann sich morgen schnell wieder ändern irgendwas passiert und die Debatte liegt wieder ganz woanders trotzalledem erleben wir in diesem Jahr sowohl mit dieser Artikel 13 Debatte als eben auch mit der ganzen Fridays for future Bewegung so eine neue Dynamisierung
der Jugend und was ich mich jetzt Frage ist ist das jetzt nur ein vorübergehendes Bild.
Ja oder haben wir es schon mit einer anderen langfristigen Politisierung zu tun die.
Vielleicht wir so auch mal wie ein Anführer sprechen so in den 80ern.
Dem Aufkommen des digitalen unsere auch erlebt haben und so als Antwort auf den Kalten Krieg und so war auf einmal alles ein bisschen anders.
Das hoffe ich natürlich.
Ich weiß jetzt nur nicht ob ich das unbedingt an an denen an dieser Konfliktlinie Jasper von altenbockum fest machen würde weil
der arbeitet sich mit teilweise nicht besonders starken Positionen.
Eben auch schon seit 30 Jahren an jeder progressiven Kraft in diesem Lande ab und das
ist er dafür ist er da ja dafür dafür hat Gott ihn geschaffen und dass das wird er tun ja und das wird er durchschaubar tun oder nicht durchschaubar
auf Twitter ist er natürlich eh so ein bisschen.
Im im Feindes Wasser wenn er das in in der Fahrt macht dann bleibt das eine Blatt eben sein,
dann kam auch mehr oder weniger unwidersprochen ja ich würde aber tatsächlich,
am weil wir beim Thema Influenza eingestiegen sind noch ein bisschen zurück auf dass es jetzt eben auch diesen angekündigten
Gesetzesentwurf gibt der in irgendeiner Weise diese Finanzierungssituation von influenza.
Transparenz verschaffen soll und da stellt sich mir natürlich schon die Frage das ist tatsächlich bei den meisten Medien mit großer Öffentlichkeit die diese verkaufen.
Geregelt ja Fernsehwerbung ist reguliert,
Fernseh Schleichwerbung ist reguliert Schleichwerbung in den öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk ist reguliert Werbefreiheit im öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk ist reguliert die Trennung von.
Redaktion und Verlag ist eine gelebte Praxis die ich glaube nicht wirklich,
reguliertes sondern sich aus journalistischer Ethik glaube ich er speist und ergibt natürlich aber auch unterstützt wird durch.
Diese Pflicht zur Kennzeichnung von Werbeanzeigen ja siehste
regelmäßig im im Spiegel oder so wenn du den liest dass das werbetreibende versuchen Ihre Anzeigen so aussehen zu lassen die Spiegel Artikel
wo dann relativ klar ist dass es offenbar eine Richtlinie gibt der die gegenüberstehen wo daneben steht okay du darfst nicht die gleiche Schrift Schriftgröße
Spalten und so weiter verwenden und außerdem dann oben diese Kennzeichnung Anzeige ist oder in in in anderen
TV Sendung früher irgendwas was ich der Preis ist heiß oder so nervo jedes einzelne Produkt was da drin war,
platziert wurde und finanziert wurde vom Hersteller oder von einer Werbeagentur jasiri meistbietend verballert hat wo dann Dauerwerbesendung dran stehen muss.
Und diese das Geschäftsmodell Aufmerksamkeit zu generieren,
für App für und mit etwas und teile diese Aufmerksamkeit zu verkaufen halte ich
nach wie vor für ein riskantes ist heißt nicht dass ich das generell falsch finde auf wenn logbuch-netzpolitik danach funktioniert dass wir es generell falsch finden.
Und ich das auch generell falsch finde es hat.
Etwas damit zu tun dass ich natürlich bemerke dass es schon gut ist.
Wenn hier eine wenn hier in irgendeiner Form Regeln Einzug erhalten und eine Pflicht zur Kennzeichnung von,
gekauften Inhalten halte ich für.
Notwendig und richtig und das ist tatsächlich schon so ein so ein Minimum ein Beispiel du kennst diese kriegst du eigentlich in vielen Städten,
und in vielen Wassers ich Stadtbezirken diese werbefinanzierten Wochenblätter ja wo dann so,
keine Ahnung wie die heißen ich.
Ja genau Berliner Woche Berliner Abendblatt und was nicht alles ja und da steht dann drin was wieder für Läden eröffnet haben dann hast du so ein schönes Portrait der
der Laden Chefin die jetzt gerade hier an dem und dem Platz im neuen Laden für bunte Kindersocken eröffnet hat und,
dann wird er ganz zeitig drüber berichtet und eine Seite später hast du halt noch eine halbseitige Werbeanzeige von denen wurde es ganz klar ist dass du mit der Werbeanzeige dieses,
redaktionelle portrait Kauf das wieder wie doch gar keinen Hehl draus gemacht ne.
Er wird nur um sie zu zeigen wo sie diese Grauzonen sind anderes Beispiel ich bin ja ein sehr.
Sehr kritisch stehe ich z.b. dieser Praxis gegenüber die in den,
USA schon lange gang und gäbe ist und in Deutschland auch immer mehr Einzug erhält das nämlich die vertraute Stimme der Podcast da nämlich die Person für den Mann ihr wieder Beziehung Vertrauensbeziehung aufgebaut hat
den Werbetext verlesen.
Wurden irgendwie Leute hört ja voll schön die Werbung stört nicht mehr so sehr nein das Gegenteil ist der Fall dass die Werbung nicht ging nicht mehr so sehr stört und dass die vertrau dir vertraute Stimme dir jetzt die Werbung ein flüstert
ist genau das was daran nicht in Ordnung ist,
das ist genau das was da gekauft wird und das wird nicht gemacht damit die Werbung nicht weniger stört sondern wird gemacht damit die Werbung bei dir besser wird.
Und ich halte das,
ich sehe ich stehe dem allen sehr sehr kritisch gegenüber und natürlich ist das ein. Wenn du im Moment in einer solch mal mehr oder weniger nicht regulierten Welt lebst und wo.
Ich heute verkaufen könnte problemlos und ein ein YouTube Video,
an irgendeinen Unternehmen bei dem ich sage hier pass auf ich machen wie du da und darüber und ich werde darin prominent,
eure Jacke tragen oder sowas und machen wir mal so und so viel Geld aus oder was du für skurrile.
Ich muss ich dann auch sagen teilweise Gerüchte eben hörst wenn du dich so mit diesen Youtuber influencer Marketing Leuten mal unterhältst,
was daneben so für für Beträge dafür übern Tisch gehen das Youtuber XY
im Hintergrund für vier Folgen irgendeine Figur oder irgendeinen Schuh oder irgendwas stehen hat oder den bei dem und dem Event trägt ja.
Ganze ganze Branche Speisen sich nur aus so etwas und natürlich ist das ist das Problem ich das problematisch ich bin dann nicht unbedingt abgeneigt.
Der These anzeigen dass das schon sinnvoll ist wenn da jetzt eine wenn da gesetzlich sich dran bemüht wird da mal in irgendeiner Form,
in Unordnung und einen Konsens reinzubringen und sei das eben diese Kennzeichnung dieses Video enthält,
platzierte Inhalte so dieses Video wurde unterstützt das,
es ist ja immer noch so dass daneben dass die die Produzenten nachher sagen können ja wir danken was weiß ich diesen und jeden.
Hersteller für Rasierer Zahnbürsten Unterhemden oder Matratzen dafür dass sie diese Sendung möglich gemacht haben und das war eben auch das erste,
das erste Modell schon bevor es Fernsehwerbung gab wurde wurden Sendungen.
Von bestimmten Herstellern gefeatured ja und ich halte das für nicht so eine blöde Idee hier ein.
Eine Regulation reinzubringen die eben da auch so ein bisschen Ordnung reinbringen das wird immer noch diesen Werbeeffekt der am Ende stattfindet kaum einen Abbruch tun was ich.
Dann immer noch ehrlich gesagt bedauern würde aber zumindest die Transparenz da herzustellen wer tatsächlich das mindeste und übrigens macht ja dieser rezo ja offenbar auch ne.
Ich verfolge das jetzt nicht aber ist natürlich schon richtig also sauber so auf die Branche selber könnte davon profitieren das hängt aber jetzt ganz davon ab.
Welche Regelung jetzt konkret
vorgeschlagen werden nur in der Hitze der aktuellen Debatte bin ich sehr gespannt wie die Debatte dann
laufen wird und insbesondere wie die Fenstern sozusagen argumentiert
habe den politische Meinungsäußerung und Werbetätigkeit in einem Kontext überhaupt zusammenstehen dürfen.
Endlich fertig.
So das war jetzt mal nicht so News getrieben aber dachten wir blicken einfach mal in die Zeit wir freuen uns natürlich auch auf eure anonym Kommentare.
Solange ihr bei uns noch anonym kommentieren dürft wir kommen zu den Kürzeren Meldungen.
Gegen Julian Assange wurde ja quasi sofort nach seinem entfernen aus der ecuadorianischen Botschaft in London am ich glaube 11 Uhr.
April ein vorläufiges Auslieferungsersuchen der USA angestrengt dieses.
Auslieferungsersuchen basierte auf einer Anklageschrift aus dem März 2018.
Erstaunlich ne dass sie gerade im März 20 18 noch mal eine eine Anklageschrift für den Grund provisorisches Auslieferung verlangen am 11. April bereit hatten ja,
und das war das mit dem Fuß eben um
conspiracy to hack a computer system geht also den Vorwurf er habe Chelsea Manning assistieren wollen ein Passwort zu knacken mit dessen Hilfe sie,
ihre,
Identität und ihre Zugriffe auf die Daten besser hätte schützen können auch das schon eine Streitfrage weil man natürlich auch sagen könnte in dem Moment wo er ihr hilft ihre.
Ihre Spuren besser zu verwischen ist er,
hilft er ihr beim Quellenschutz und beim identitätsschutz die andere Perspektive darauf ist er macht sich hier
ein Schritt zu weit als Journalist der nämlich zwar Daten entgegennehmen darf aber nicht anstiften oder dabei assistieren darf die zu erlangen lange Diskussion.
Frage stellt sich aber natürlich ist das ausreichend für eine Auslieferung Julien Assange is in the usa deswegen.
Gibt es jetzt eine zweite Anklageschrift die quasi ausführlichere bei der 17 neue Anklagepunkte hinzugekommen sind die aus dem Mai 2019 stammt nicht man sieht ja also diese,
it in Virginia war das glaube ich da hat man erstmal so einen Sprint gemacht ja schon mal kurz und dann noch mal lang 17 Anklagepunkte mehr dabei eben auch.
Die,
die Vergehen nach dem espionnage für die eben auch viel an ganz andere Strafen im Raume stehen als als die die jetzt hier dieses conspiracy to Hecke Computersystem ich glaube da war die Höchststrafe 5 Jahre.
Wir hatten auch glaube ich schon darüber berichtet dass diese 17.9 Anklagepunkte eben die maximal sentences ihn irgendwie weiß nicht wie viele hundert Jahre in Knast bringen würden da haben sie.
Ja irgend sowas aber nur 10343 das schon berichtet aber auf Basis dieser.
17.9 Anklagepunkte zusätzlich zu den anderen aus dem März in deine wurde jetzt auch tatsächlich das Auslieferungsersuchen das Finale was jetzt eben auch formal relevant ist,
Andy Andy Andy UK gestellt werden ja gesagt das ist quasi dass das provisorische I war quasi hier übrigens wir melden schon mal Bedarf an und dann hatten sie bestimmte Zeit noch das Final zu formulieren.
Und jetzt kurz vor Ende der Deadline haben sie das eben angebracht die Schätzung ist,
das ist jetzt ungefähr zwei bis fünf Jahre dauert bis über diese Auslieferung dann final entschieden wird allein schon aufgrund der Menge der Anklagepunkte und der
Fragen des internationalen Rechts der natürlich von verschiedenen Seiten die in diesem Verfahren beteiligt sind zu erwartenden Verzögerungen.
Das heißt das wird uns die nächsten Jahre begleiten.
Weiterhin gibt es einen spannenden Artikel nicht in dem Kontext nur noch mal erwähnen möchte der auf zeit.de heute erschienen ist Assange es sieben Jahre wo eben darüber gesprochen wurde was das.
Sieben lange Jahre was es aus jemanden macht der eben 7.
Jahre in Einzelhaft ist,
was das also in auch also binnen kürzester Zeit macht also Schlafstörung Appetitverlust Panik Wutanfälle teilweise selbstschädigendes Verhalten Suizidgedanken Wahnvorstellungen Lethargie.
Höhere Sensitivität gegenüber reizen und ewigen ehrlichen,
sie neigen zu endlosen Grübeln ja was willst du auch sonst machen wenn du irgendwie ne 23 Stunden allein im stillen Kämmerchen eingesperrt bist und keine Reize bekommst da wird noch mal,
auch auf über die sehr krassen Bedingungen den Joannis Horch jetzt eben schon seit längerem ausgesetzt ist,
aus kompetenter Perspektive Berichte.
Ja Julia Soundstation der Sinne leaking webseite Betrieben paar auch nicht war auch nicht schlecht ne hat ihm dann nur halt nachhaltig Feinde gemacht aber ja du jetzt ein Podcast gemacht und hätte sich über Kommentare ärgern.
Das Datenleck der Woche sein nur sein nur sein nur kurz erwähnt in den USA wurden.
Für anderthalb Monate an einem nicht genannten Grenzübergang Fotos,
von den Leuten gemacht die ein und ausgereist sind mit Kennzeichen also irgendwie vom Auto mit,
mit dem Kennzeichen also man sieht die Person und das Kennzeichen aber keine Sorge es sind weniger als 100.000 Fotos also für heutige liegen Maßstäbe quasi.
Irrelevant und das wurde als Test und Lernmaterial an einen Dienstleister gegeben der eben damit arbeiten sollte und dann kam.
Nee der kleine Haki und jetzt sind diese Daten eben gestohlen worden keiner weiß von wem keiner weiß wo sie hin sind im Datennetz sind sie immer noch nicht aufgetaucht aber.
Auch das natürlich wieder nur ein Vorgeschmack für solche Video erfassungs und Überwachungssysteme die.
In den nächsten Jahren
in den USA und natürlich auch in Deutschland ausgerollt werden sollen und das erinnert übrigens sie auch an den Nacktscanner Fällen inzwischen haben uns ja schon fast daran gewöhnt dass die,
natürlich nicht als Nacktscanner sondern als terahertz wellen Scanner bezeichneten
Körperscanner an den Flughäfen stehen von den uns immer versprochen wurde sie würden keine Nacktbilder speichern außer zu
bitte wecken um die Dienstleistung und den Service stetig zu verbessern auch die waren ja schon massenhaft gelegt
und so passiert es eben auch mit Kamera überwachungs und Kennzeichenerfassung System in den USA.
Ja aber das bringt uns jetzt zu den Termin.
Ja an Termin ist der Sommer natürlich nicht arm und wir nehmen deshalb nur 1 Hamilton jetzt eingereicht.
Vom 26 bis 28 07 findet in Berlin im ullsteinhaus.
Hecke von für Seenotrettung mithilfe Drohnen basierter Bilderkennung Stadt veranstaltet wird das ganze von AA for good.
Und es geht dabei um das seawatch Projekt oder sea-watch Projekt haben wir hier in logbuch-netzpolitik glaube ich schon öfter,
er berichtet aber geht es darum quasi mit einer Drohne die das Mittelmeer ab fliegt schneller und besser Schiffbrüchige und in sono Seenot gerettete Menschen zu erkennen.
Um dann seenotrettungs Missionen gezielter direkt dorthin bringen zu können und die nicht mehr einfach orientierungslos auf und abfahren lassen zu müssen.
Denke das ist ein interessantes und spannendes Projekt.
Gerade Bilderkennung in im Bereich eben auch gehobener Anspruch und deswegen hier von uns der terminhinweis für diejenigen die da schon einige Erfahrung mit gesammelt haben und daran mitwirken möchte.
Link und Anmeldung gibt's wie immer bei uns in den.
Damit sie war am Ende dieser Diskussions freudigen Sendung angekommen.
Davon zu schönen über Refinanzierung und werbungs Modelle und so weiter unterhalten haben sei es uns freigestellt an der Stelle auch mal über,
und das noch mal kurz zu reden wir machen nämlich keine Werbung weil wir das nicht gut finden und war aber auch keine Lust haben.
Und mit so Werbetreibenden auch überhaupt auch nur darüber auseinanderzusetzen welchen Werten irgendwie diese Zielgruppe ja haben könnte,
der Wert der Zielgruppe der bleibt mal ganz unser eigener wert das ist uns an der Stelle sehr wichtig.
Trotzdem könnt ihr das natürlich dann auch
unterstützen und viele von euch tun das ja auch schon insbesondere mit Daueraufträgen das finden wir auch total super sollten weitere von euch
das tun wollen dann können wir das noch superer kleiner Hinweis an der Stelle gibt so ein paar Leute und habe ich auch eigentlich gar nichts gegen die benutzen auch PayPal für regelmäßige Zahlung.
Kann man machen aber da kommt dann so ab und zu mal so ein Euro Spenden wo Peppa Land einfach mal so 37 Cent gleich wieder an Gebühren abzieht also,
das können wir noch mal überdenken und an der Stelle vielleicht das offene SEPA-Überweisung umstellen oder wenn er,
PayPal benutzen wollt oder müsst aus irgendwelchen Gründen.
Höhere Beträge.
Man kann es ja anders Staffeln irgendwie einmal im Jahr ist er vollkommen egal aber so grundsätzlich ist einfach eine regelmäßige Unterstützung dabei ist die Höhe der Spende ist mir an der Stelle wirklich ziemlich egal wichtig ist dass man sieht dass Leute.
Das ja auch gut finden und begleiten und unterstützen möchten und.
Wenn das halt viele machen kommt auch was dabei zusammen ne schreibt in die Produktion schreibt in die Überweisung.
Schaue noch ziemlich shoutout Überweisung.
Niechorze Überweisung schreibt er dann lnp rein damit wir das auch zuordnen können oder eben auch alle anderen podcast.de Metaebene selbstverständlich die euch Freude bereiten Ja und.
Also ich sag dann kann das ja sogar die Zuordnung hilft mir wenn ich wenn ihr nur den Schirm unterstützen wollt dann macht er keine Zuordnung.
Genau oder hörte nur die anderen podcast.de Metaebene zu das könnt ihr auch machen nein man sieht halt daran auch sehr schön was sozusagen zusagt,
ihr macht das schon wir wollt und ihr macht es sicherlich.
Andere Wege und zu danken und zu unterstützen sind ja sowieso noch verlinkt in den,
in den jeweiligen shoutouts und Namen und so weiter auch wenn Gäste bei uns sind findet ihr immer z.b. deren unterschiedliche was dass ich Bitcoin Adressen Amazon Wunschlisten und sonstiges
an der jeweiligen Person verlinkt und so können wir dieses Programm mit Freude weiter für euch.
Auf deiner Wunschliste steht ja immer was drauf das ist ja auch sehr schön und auf meiner nicht.
Das hast du die machen wunschlos glücklich denn das nervt die Leute sich.
Naja es ist halt nur nicht so dass mich jetzt einfach nur die die Produkte des Kapitalismus allein glücklich machen wird ne.
Ich trinke Kaffee ist halt der Kaffee den ich trinke es selten ein Produkt des Kapitalismus ja der wird immer von,
Kaisers Rose himself in Guatemala gepflückt und so.
Von den von denen zapatistisch im kollektivem und so weiter deswegen ist so teuer.
Ich bin noch so ein gebranntes Kind aus NSFW Zeit da hat sich einfach irgendwie so viel Tante auf einmal aufgetürmt und das braucht dich alles gar nicht aber stimmt.
Das fand ich übrigens auch der fand ich auch sehr interessant bei NSFW ne.
Nathema influencer-marketing bei NSFW ging das ja damals los dass ihr mal das eine oder andere wohlmeinende Zusendung passende Geschenk bekommen habt es dauerte glaube ich nicht so lange bis dann auch so
die ein oder andere Firma mal euch etwas schickte so auch aber wir schicken euch wir schenken euch unser neues Produkte,
zur Besprechung in der Sendung ja.
Also das ist schon sehr sehr der der der Kampf gegen die Vereinnahmung ist wirklich ein ein anstrengender.
Ja das ist und dann kann man auch mal dazu sagen das ist auch.
Für einen selbst psychologisch schwierig ne weil es wird sehr schnell klar was,
die eigene Öffentlichkeit,
ja dieser Influenz den man da hat sie auch eine Influenza wert sein könnte wenn man den bereit ist sie auch konsequent zu vermag.
Und in dem Moment wo man darauf verzichtet das zu tun.
Böser entgeht einem unterm Strich Geld wenn man das jetzt so rechnet von Susan vom Ende her ne was könnte theoretisch herauskommen wenn ich das jetzt dieses Prinzip maximiere.
Und das ist nicht.
Seesand einfach klingt jetzt ein bisschen blöd ne aber es ist auf jeden Fall immer so eine so eine so eine Verlockung ist immer so eine Karotte die vor allem hin und her geschwenkt.
Insofern bin ich da eigentlich sehr zufrieden mit dem neuen Modell.
Oder mit diesem konsequenten Modell mit einfach nur zu sagen zoel wenn es euch gefällt machten Dauerauftrag.
Der Betrag spielt am Ende keine Rolle dass umso mehr Leute sich daran beteiligen umso besser funktioniert es auch und für mich hat das einfach den Vorteil dass ich nicht,
Lindsay Gruppendenken muss ja und du ja auch nicht das finde ich so dieses worüber sollten wir jetzt reden ja.
Deutsche was kriegt sich was will was interessiert die Leute was über die bleiben sie länger dran ja,
oder im schlimmsten Fall die was hat am Ende auch noch,
mehr mit den Themen zu tun wo unsere Werbepartner herkommen haasower dann haben wir es hier auch noch ein Anbieter für verschlüsselte Telefone am Ende noch irgendwie als Sponsoren finden wir ja nur noch,
nur noch über dieses Thema oder tendieren vielleicht noch dazu da irgendwelche Bedrohungsszenarien wiederholt runter zu beten.
Das weitere dass das andere Problem ist ja vor allem selbst wenn wir das nicht tun würden.
Würde der Zweifel immer nah bleiben.
Wenn wir also jetzt sagen ok wir nehmen um Sponsoring von z.b. in dieser Sendung einem verschlüsselten messenger ne was.
Im im Zweifelsfall so der der der Teil wäre wo wir sagen können ja das ist ethisch vertretbar das ist ein Produkt was wir unter Umständen sogar selber nutzen von denen den wir doch gerne Geld und denkt ihr voranzubringen Aschau.
Und solche solche genau so ein Angebot hatte ich auch schon.
Genau genau deswegen nehme ich also ein Beispiel und jetzt hätte es jetzt wäre das der die Frage könnt ihr dann.
Unserer politischen unseren politischen Äußerungen zu dem Themenbereich in den kommenden Sendungen überhaupt noch trauen im Zweifelsfall schon aber der der ne da bleiben einfach Fragen offen.
Justine dippl.
Werbung für Nippelklemmen machen wir.
Also wenn ihr Nippelklemmen herstellt und hier Werbung schalten wollt geht klar.
Linus.
Iris ist nett es ist wie mit dem Rauchen leber gar nicht.
Das hast du so schön gesagt er möchte ich dir gleich die Oreo Flecken.
Wird noch Werbung für Hunde machen.
Auf jeden Fall Reso finde für den Feed Chris aufjedenfall like von mir kein Audio.
Von mir kriegt er von mir kriegt ein bisschen Oreo Creme.
Von die Christen in der Klemme so das war's jetzt hier mit dem Albernheiten für sagen tschüss bis Wismar.
Das tun werden aber ich danke noch kurz den Jens und damit zurück ins Internet ciao ciao.